he said he didn't think bathroom bills
were a good use of his time you can go
look that up I signed a bathroom bill in
Florida so that's obviously not
true one of the things that came up and
has consistently come up is that Ronda
santis doesn't just say the things that
he's going to do he has a track record
of doing all the things that he says and
Nicki Haley accused Ronda santis of not
signing a bathroom bill here in Florida
meaning that it stop boys from going
into girls bathrooms take a look at this
and this shows how hypocritical Ron
continues to be when he was running for
governor and they asked him about that
he said he didn't think bathroom bills
were a good use of his time you can go
look that up I signed a bathroom bill in
Florida so that's obviously not
true so the idea that you would say that
I was sign sign you didn't you killed it
I signed it I stood up for little girls
you didn't do it and there was this
going on I was actually just in South
Carolina some of the legislators told me
at the time there were boys going into
the girls that's the whole reason why
they did it and so they say when she
does that explanation that that doesn't
hold water and this is the upstate of
South Carolina I signed the bill I
protected the girl car did not do you
know sou Carol because okay putting us
out the little tit for Tad drama yes
Ronda santz did sign the bathroom Bill
she completely made that up here you go
I'm not going to read the whole for you
but it's hb1 1521 Ronda santis signed it
and it stopped boys from going into
girls bathrooms and girls from going
into boys bathrooms Nikki Haley never
signed such a bill so she flat out lied
and once again and and this is the
competency issue that Dan santis has
just saying the right thing and saying
the truth it doesn't go viral but I
think for those of us that actually care
about the truth and care about
competency and care about America we
have to just stand up and and reiterate
when actual truth is is presented on
that stage uh here's Dan santis going a
little bit further on Haley when it
comes to women's sports and I also say
that biological boys shouldn't be
playing in girl Sports and I will do
everything I can to stop that because
it's the women's issue of our time leg
protect women sports I get this done
yeah again it's quick but it's him
saying I've done it I've done it I'm the
one that signed the stuff right so they
she's saying okay I'll do it I will do
it when president I'm going to keep
girls out or keep boys out of girl
Sports and the santis again just I've
done it and in some ways maybe that
should have been the Sis's tagline the
entire time like I've done it whatever
you people are complaining about I've
done
it